the
final question and the hardest one I
love them I love my family I like my
wife my children are the most important
people for me
I do not get to see them often
my parents
I don't have
uh
any opportunities to see them
I'm very proud
of my wife
I know what kind of person she is and I
know that she's doing everything she can
for the sake of
children in the country and of course
it's a great thing for her to do
something for the sake of me well on a
joke and note they're all in my heart of
course
and I was actually honest with you but I
said that this is the the hardest
question and I'm having a hard time
finding words the most important thing
is not to let them down
the most important thing is to make sure
that my children are proud of me
and I am happy that they're in Ukraine
that they go to the Ukrainian
universities it is very important for
president of Ukraine
foreign
War you have to be here because the men
and women are dying here and it's
important for your wife and your
children to be here I cannot order them
to be here
what's important is that
they are this kind of people and I'm
very lucky to have this family and this
country